humo negro tanques militares y
detonaciones
durante más de un mes los sudaneses
atrapados en jartum han sido testigos de
esta desolación los violentos combates
han empujado acerca de un millón de
sudaneses a las carreteras como en este
campamento en por Sudán al este del país
uno de cada dos daneses necesita ayuda
humanitaria
un misil cayó sobre la casa de nuestro
vecino nos asustó y decidimos irnos de
todos modos no había agua ni
electricidad ni leche para alimentar a
mis hijos
la ONU Calcula ahora que necesitaría
2600 millones de dólares para hacer
frente a la emergencia pero el reto no
es solo financiero a pesar del
compromiso firmado por ambas partes en
conflicto la ayuda humanitaria está en
el punto de
Mirad
se han producido violaciones
significativas y flagrantes de la
declaración desde que se firmó se
suponía que la firma de este documento
sobre la ayuda humanitaria garantizaría
que no se produjeran ataques contra el
personal o las instalaciones
humanitarias y han habido
el programa mundial de alimentos perdió
existencias de productos por valor de 56
millones de dólares la fábrica que
producía el 60% de los tratamientos
nutricionales para niños desnutridos
también desapareció en la actual cumbre
de la liga árabe donde están
representados los beligerantes se supone
que diseñarán corredores humanitarios
para dejar salir a los civiles y
permitir la entrada de ayuda hasta ahora
no se ha tenido